thanks to our friends at libs of tick
tock
we know that a middle school teacher
in florida
is very very furious because
in florida it is increasingly
frowned upon
to try to trans little kids
my state decided that it was a good idea
to ban the use of the word gay in the
classroom educators can now not are not
allowed to say gay in the classroom
anymore
this is a life or death issue
why do i say that
one of the most important
statistics that i use in my curriculum
when teaching anti-oppression
specifically about lgbtqia issues is 72
percent
you decrease the likelihood of a young
trans person of wanting to commit
suicide if all you do is use the proper
pronouns
for that person
72 percent
you can save a life by using one
often two-letter word
for a person
misgendering someone can have them go on
a spiral where they don't want to live
anymore
and now we're not allowed to say gay
even if we are gay
even if we have
an openly same sex relationship
even if we are openly non-binary or
trans as per as educators we cannot talk
about who we are we exist
i've got one really important statistic
for you to know when you are watching
libs on tick tock and that statistic is
four hundred and twenty percent four 420
percent of the statistics that libs on
tick tock cite are completely made up
420
you can reduce your risk of losing iq
points 420
by not watching libs on tick tock i
obviously don't believe this statistic
this woman is citing that 72 you're
if you don't call boys she and girls he
then you are going to encourage them to
commit suicide and if only you call them
by the wrong pronoun then you'll
decrease their suicide
suicidality by 70 plus percent i just
don't believe that and one of the
reasons i don't believe that is because
this woman is saying a whole lot of
things in this video that i know for a
fact are not true
like you're not allowed to say gay in
classrooms in florida that's just not
true that just isn't true at all that's
completely made up it's nowhere in the
florida education bill
and it's just not the case the the woman
is uh saying that she is non-binary well
that's not true because that's not
possible that's not that's not a real
thing so she isn't that so she's
she's wrong she i'm not saying she's a
liar but she's certainly mistaken right
now go to expressvpn
michael y t
you've got to protect your data from
being tracked and the people that i
trust expressvpn
i do not open up
an electronic device without expressvpn
on it it's super easy to set up just one
click of a button goes online otherwise
every time you search for something
every time you watch a video every time
you click a link it's getting tracked by
big tech by the three letter government
agencies sometimes by both and anytime
they want they can match your activity
to your actual identity using your
device's unique ip address when you turn
on expressvpn
they can't see your ip address at all
your identity is anonymized with a
secure vpn server
super easy you just you open it up on
that phone on that tablet on that laptop
you click the button no big deal stop
handing your data over to the government
and big tech defend your rights with the
vpn that i use and trust expressvpn.com
michael yt
use that url get three extra months for
free or click the link in the
description below she says that she
teaches anti-oppression in the classroom
where does that fit in in the in the
school day schedule is that so for you
have home room in the morning
then you've got social studies maybe
then math class then anti-oppression and
then
english language and arts is that
in literature is that what you've got i
don't know where is anti-oppression no
this woman is a radical political
activist
who is using taxpayer dollars in florida
i think that's the state that she's in
right yeah she's using taxpayer dollars
to indoctrinate little kids into her
radical weird leftist ideologies she
says i'm not even allowed to be open
about my same-sex relationships in the
classroom you certainly shouldn't be
yeah i don't i don't want you teaching
that in the classroom that's weird don't
talk about your sex life in the
classroom
period no i don't think you should be
talking about your sex life in any grade
but certainly not in k through 3 or
pre-k until third grade certainly not
if only you
use the
wrong pronouns then you will save a life
even if it were true i know it's not
true
but even if it were true it would still
be wrong this kind of emotional
blackmail is the way to madness
because it actually
this is
kind of a strange connection and it ties
in with another creepy weird sex thing
but when i was at yale with senator cruz
last week we were asked a question by
this kid who obviously just wanted to
get some headlines and tell a joke he
said if it would end world hunger would
you
perform a certain sex act on another man
and it was funny and people laughed in
the room
but it's actually not a complicated
question the answer is no
i wouldn't do that
no it wouldn't end world hunger
no calling kids the wrong pronoun isn't
going to reduce their suicidality or
depression or anxiety it's probably
going to increase it by hardening their
gender dysphoria
but
no i wouldn't do that because that's
called consequentialism
that's that's
that's called the ends justify the means
that is a morally idiotic way of viewing
the world that's called it takes a few
a few broken eggs to make an omelette
that logic that by committing an
intrinsically disordered evil action
you might achieve some good end that has
been used to justify the worst crimes in
history and it's morally incoherent and
it doesn't lead to good outcomes
anyway
glad you liked that clip now please
ring the bell subscribe get all the
notifications check out i got this great
new video where we were at washburn
university and i i actually ended up
sitting down with the gal who organized
a protest against me really really
surprising exchange go check it out
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you